[Aplausos]
pensemos um dia acordar e deixar o bebê
depois da cheia a crescer a respirar a
multiplicar a evoluir e é a evoluir ea
multiplicação nós olhariam cederemos a
vida acabou só de uma forma mais poética
acabou a maioria das coisas vivas não é
acharemos que tenhamos ficado cegos não
é bom não é o propósito
o propósito é que o propósito é que nós
estaríamos perante uma situação em que
aprenderemos a ver a vida aprender e eu
já conhecia e a dar importância à vida
essa dinâmica das coisas vivas ao dos
seus livros é que me fascinou durante
todo o tempo do meu tempo vida e motivou
me interessou a debitar é a iniciativas
para conhecer compreender e valorizar
conservar you e acima de tudo respeitar
coisas vivas e assim aprender a
desenvolver uma capacidade de observação
das coisas vividas no dia a dia e é
sobre essas observações do dia a dia que
eu gostaria de partilhar convosco não as
inquietações mas a capacidade que eu
acho que terá transformadora e nossos
tempos humanos de usar a consciência de
uma forma muito positiva
gostaria de convidar a fazer uma pequena
a viagem mental sobre a alma das coisas
que fazemos ou do que fazemos as coisas
vivas ser tiverem paciência e fizerem
essa viagem comigo é assim nós o cheiro
humano com toda a nossa inteligência com
toda a nossa capacidade com todo o nosso
conhecimento e com o desenvolvimento da
tecnologia
acabamos nos separando se desconectando
do planeta
desligamos natureza da natureza que
proporciona tudo aquilo que nós
precisamos para viver certa forma
desligarmos já deixamos de ter aquela
ligação complementa quem é e ciência que
proporciona toda a todos os sistemas e
todo chu os mecanismos que suportam a
vida certo é quanto toda a nossa
evolução desenvolvemos um paradigma de
separação em relação ao planeta devemos
a nós ea os outros seres vivos sejam
plantas sejam animais sejam um sucesso
sejam microorganismos completamente
desligado e completamente separados do
planeta
temos a noção de que vivemos num planeta
nós vemos completamento isolado enquanto
completamente dissociado deu
isso levou a desenvolver se
desenvolvesse um paradigma de separação
e em infelizmente enquanto que exceder
esse paradigma da declaração adotarmos
uma forma de ser e de estar com o
planeta que é completamente eu diria um
pouco desastrosa
vou passar aqui alguns exemplos que vão
fazer ver até quando podemos porque
podemos chegar a essa conclusão ao
abordar um gesto paradigma de separação
por exemplo modelar nosso planeta ao
destruir espécie expressão tanto
espécies terrestres condição espécies
marinhas
1 quanto vale office e acabam entrando
no domínio de espécies espécies
distintas gás em vias de extinção
ao adotarmos o nosso paradigma de
separação
destruímos árvores seculares existem
florestas que levaram tempos milhares e
milhares de duas centenas de anos a
crescer e fazemos com que o planeta seja
desprovido do sistema que o faz respirar
e que o faz ser reciclado
o co2 a consequência disso nós passar
dados são as mudanças climáticas que são
as observadas em alguns casos quando
estão acompanhados por outros factores
pc aliam a provocar as mudanças
climáticas que nem a poluição industrial
outro aspecto que é patente quando
provocado ano estávamos a desflorestação
é por exemplo a desertificação eo
planeta responde é isto com escassez de
água à escassez da água que afeta
pessoas que afeta plantas que afeta
animais como resultado das investigação
também ocorre o fenômeno queimadas por
exemplo que estamos muito aquém do poder
controlar a ferramenta chamada espanha
contido nos últimos anos tem acompanhado
os noticiários por ter se espalham por
províncias cada vez maiores e atende ou
consomem o próprio substrato que devia
fazer parte do que devia ser a base da
constituição de novas espécies
ao adotarmos o nosso paradigma de
separação o que fazemos com os ser como
o ser humano
provocamos por exemplo a poluição
ambiental e enchemos o marido de
plástico plástico e se perpetua e ciclos
de identificação de espécies marinhas
perpetua problemas de saúde está próximo
demais marinhas como para as pessoas em
viabilizar a tanto a capacidade do
próprio dos tops oceano e servirem como
fonte de subsistência para a vida da
humanidade enquanto conhecer isso
fazemos projeções muito sombrias sobre o
futuro da humanidade sobre a
sustentabilidade do planeta e sobre a
sustentabilidade do próximo próprio
cinema
o nosso paradigma de separação e estamos
por exemplo os se a natureza dos seres
vivos exemplo que determinadas espécies
desenvolvem características novas como
resposta à ação como resposta à
intervenção humana
estamos lembrados por exemplo que eu não
sei que ouviram falar
vocês sabem que um terço dos elefantes
que na china' na gloriosa nascem com um
elefante fêmea foi na bossa nascem como
nasceu o chifre sem as empresas e isso é
uma reação é uma reação praticamente da
natureza a defender-se da predação
humana isto bem importado é vendo
importada
bem comportado num trabalho da national
geographic feito por uma cientista que
vai trabalhar na bossa e que seja essa
observação tem desenhos muito lindos do
dos elefantes sem chifres
isto é portanto uma reação da natureza
que surge quando o homem não acho o
suficiente o que é uma pena
nosso paradigma de separação ainda leva
nos a qui consumamos em excesso
estranhámos percursos da natureza sem
atentados para a função no planeta e sem
atentar nos para a sua natureza finita
o que acontece é perder pois temos
problemas sérios com a base de sustentar
o passe de sustentação da própria
humanidade ficamos sempre o curso eu
ficamos com medo que haja recursos para
suportarem os bilhões pelos tentos de
mutantes que ainda vão passar antes pelo
planeta
nosso sistema furiosa no paradigma de
separação leva ainda é que mantemos
microônibus microorganismos que no geral
com os empenhos um papel muito
importante em funções vitais complexas
no organismo no solo e no mar por
exemplo
vocês sabiam ter o nosso organismo está
carregado de micróbios
alguém vai pensar que não só o organismo
do vizinho é que é esse problema
pensando errado qualquer um de nós tem
um montão de micróbios dentro desse
exemplo só o nosso intestino tem
trilhões de micróbios que executam
funções muito importantes para a nossa
saúde tanto física como a saúde mental
combate às doenças
e também é que regula o nosso sistema
imunológico
quem é o fenômeno muito interessante
porque só agora é que se está a
descobrir essa relação entre os
micróbios e à saúde o que vai abrir
caminho vai facilitar com que acha novas
formas de tratamento tanto de doenças
mentais como dando doenças crônicas por
exemplo
isto é um daqueles exemplos que mostra
que quando nos abrimos para a natureza e
abrimos a nossa nossa cabeça para
trabalhar com ela
a natureza se adaptar a nós
coopera conosco e revela seus segredos e
muitos mais segredos vai à natureza do
palácio estaremos abertos a admitir essa
essa possibilidade pelo paradigma de
separação ainda outro exemplo é que nós
matamos os insetos porque temos medo
deus
os insetos as sugestões era só uma
importância dos insetos
eu iria ficar o jonas ressalta que desde
uma coisa que é muito ilustrativa e
muito importante é que se todos os
insetos desaparecessem da terra todas as
formas de vida na terra teria um fim
acabariam mas se todos os humanos
desaparecem da terra todas as formas de
vida
florez seriam este é um 26 das cotações
baixas sofridas da minha vida
estúpido de estudo e eu gostaria só que
pensássemos será que é assim que nós
queremos ser vistos
será que somos assim tão dispensáveis e
ficamos contentes com ser tão
dispensáveis
por que não sermos os insetos por
exemplo e proporcionarmos que
a vida na terra a floresta e produza
diversidade
prometemos que podemos continuar assim
ora o planeta passa por essas coisas
todas que não fica parado não fica
quieto porque não é passivo não é meta
o planeta sempre o planeta foi ágil o
planeta funda e ele acha tudo aquilo p
ao todo o mal que a gente possa
infringir é um planeta é certa forma
inteligente faz a maior parte das coisas
que qualquer um dos seus amigos fácil e
é portanto pode-se concluir que o
planeta é vivo eo planeta é então
vigente
se escutarmos a voz do planeta
nós percebemos que teremos que adotar um
novo paradigma uma nova forma de ser e
de estar com planeta uma nova forma de
nos relacionarmos com o planeta se
escutassem os avós do planeta
havíamos de perceber que tudo aquilo que
fazemos e tudo aquilo que acontece que
seja obra das nossas isso nos nossos
pensado nosso pensamento do nosso leite
ter reflexos muito negativos no planeta
e que portanto deveria ser pintada
se fosse nos escutar a voz do planeta
havia me perceber que mudando o
paradigma padre julgamento para que haja
uma nova consciência para que se crie
uma nova mentalidade tenhamos uma nova
atitude em relação à nossa forma de ser
e de estar com o planeta
se fossemos a pensar ea sentir como
tendo o planeta
veríamos a necessidade
adotar uma nova consciência e douglas
todos relacionados com o planeta de uma
forma diferente
eu convido vos pois há uma nova
consciência e desde que a mudança começa
comigo que reconheço que os problemas do
planeta são meus problemas são teus
problemas são problemas de todos nós e
portanto a solução para esses problemas
também dependa de todos nós
gostaria de convidar vos aqui no
dia-a-dia pensassem 10 segundos em ser o
planeta que adotassem uma atitude dp
o planeta é é a minha vida o planeta é
responsável por mim mesma forma começou
propõs ável pelo planeta
gostaria que adotássemos uma atitude de
eu sou o planeta
eu sou o início no planeta porque o
planeta é o primeiro apresenta gostaria
t todos nós
abraço assim o seu planeta porque o
planeta é cada um de nós
brilha
[Aplausos]